Everyone, Bonnie made a friend in class...
no no she literally made a new friend
I want you to meet... Forky!
Hi
Hello
Ahh!
he's a spork
yes, yeah. I know.
Forky is the most important toy to Bonnie right now
we all have to make sure nothing happens to him
Woody! We have a situation.
I am not a toy!
I was made for soup, salad, maybe chili
...and then the trash!
Freedom!
Buzz, we've got to get Forky
affirmative
why am I alive?
You're Bonnie's toy.
you are going to help create happy memories that will last for the rest of her life
huh?
what?
Bo?
Forky, come on
hi there
my name is Gaby Gaby
we can't stay
yes you can
boys
Woody, behind you
Bo! What are you doing here?
no time to explain, come with me
we need to get back to our kid
ah, Sheriff Woody, always coming to the rescue
Bonnie needs Forky
Woody, who needs a kid's room when you can have all of this
wow
Woody
aren't we going to Bonnie?
we have to find them
what do we do Buzz?
what would Woody do?
jump out of a moving vehicle
Let's go!
hey, if you gotta go you gotta go
you know, you've handled this lost toy life better than I could
open your eyes Woody there's plenty of kids out there
sometimes change can be good
you can't teach this old toy new tricks
you'd be surprised
Bonnie?
we're going home Forky
Bonnie, I'm coming!
on my way Woody
too infinity and beyond!
ka boom!
don't let Woody leave
kids lose their toys everyday
I was made to help a child
I don't remember it being this hard
Woody, somebody's whispering in your ear
everything's going to be okay